It might feel a little weird that
we're going to be using Android Studio
to load up a project that's only
partially about Android, but
it'll make a ton more sense once we
talk about the Gradle build system.
So how does a game turn from source code
in your editor into a form you can run?
Well there's actually way more code
in a LibGDX game than just the code
you're going to write.
There's all the middleware that
defines the LibGDX APIs, and
then there's all the code for
whatever backend you're building.
To compile your game, all the relevant
code will need to be collected,
compiled, and linked.
Not only that, but your game will likely
feature resources like images and
sounds, which will need to
be processed and packaged.
Building an Android project
is even more complicated.
As it needs to know about all
of your resources before any of
the Java gets compiled.
This is starting to sound
like a nightmare, right?
Well, thankfully,
the Gradle build system knows how
to handle pretty much all of this.
A Gradle project is described in one or
more build.gradle files,
which define what sort of project is
being built, where the code lives, and
what external libraries are being used.
Finally, how to package the output.
Gradle also exposes a list of tasks that
define what Gradle knows how to do with
the source files and
the resources it has.
Full disclosure, the course I made
before this one was all about Gradle and
how it makes Android builds awesome.
So what does this have to
do with Android studio?
Well, Gradle is very tightly
integrated into Android Studio.
In fact,
Android Studio will happily import and
build any project that uses Gradle.
Android Studio maintains its own
internal model of what your project
looks like, which is how it does
cool stuff like auto-importing and
code completion.
This also means that when it imports
a Gradle project, or when one of
the .gradle files changes, Android
Studio has to synchronize its internal
model of the project with the model
of the project as defined by Gradle.
So, if you ever see Android Studio
complaining about having to
sync with Gradle.
That's what's going on.